hablamos ahora de temas económicos en
france24 y estamos para eso con danger
hablando aunque nos va a contar lo más
importante de esta jornada ni la
bienvenida vamos a hablar del reino
unido de la unión europea que se alistan
para un break sheet sin acuerdo liliana
buenas noches mire terminó el plazo
establecido por el primer ministro
británico y el break si te está quedando
sin oxígeno porque la distancia con
bruselas parece ser cada vez mayor así
que lo más probable es que las
relaciones comerciales entre ellos se
rija desde 2021 por las normas de la
organización mundial del comercio la
unión europea reiteró hoy que está
dispuesta a negociar pero no a cualquier
precio y desde downing street-
respondieron en un tono menos optimista
hemos llegado al escenario por desgracia
donde no parecen querer avanzar en un
acuerdo de libre comercio eso fue
bastante claro a partir de las
conclusiones de la cumbre no quieren ir
más lejos a menos que eso cambie
fundamentalmente tendremos que salir en
términos australianos pero prosperaremos
enormemente de todos modos australia
costa mayuli honduras
hablamos de américa latina- daniela y
argentina que tiene el dólar dispararle
mercado ilegal y sigue tomando medidas
para frenar sus lidian a ese país ha
venido luchando por hacerle frente a la
constante fuga de dólares por ejemplo
hace un mes el gobierno impuso
restricciones a la compra en el mercado
oficial sin embargo la reacción en pocas
semanas es que el llamado dólar blue que
es el que se vende de manera paralela no
encuentra techo este viernes se vendió a
un precio récord de 175 pesos argentinos
es decir más del doble de lo que vale
hoy un dólar en el banco de la nación
que son unos 80 y 25 pesos pero el
gobierno defiende sus medidas escuchemos
diluye contado con liquidación son dos
dólares que no importan de forma directa
en la economía sino que importan vía lo
que generan para las expectativas
la brecha importa por lo que hace sobre
las expectativas de sal ahora la
realidad es que esos tipos de cambio hoy
están en valores que no representan la
realidad argentina también hablamos de
francia porque el gobierno lanzó un
programa para recaudar préstamos para
pequeños empresarios se trata de un
esquema por medio del cual las
microempresas que se han visto afectadas
por la pandemia pueden acceder a
préstamos bancarios como ahora los
bancos son más reservados para prestar
el dinero liliana lo que hará el
gobierno de manuel macro es respaldar
justamente esos créditos para que los
beneficiados sean los que se quebraron
en esta pandemia y no antes
la idea es ponerlo en marcha desde el
próximo año y recaudar unos 20 mil
millones de euros en este país las
quiebras corporativas han caído a
niveles no vistos desde 1989 y cocacola
saldrá de casi la mitad de sus marcas
por culpa de la pandemia así es
nacional anunció que comenzará con la
marca tapa no sé si alguno de ustedes la
conocen mi mamá si la conoce por lo
menos ésta fue lanzada en el mercado en
1963 y era la bebida dietética más
popular de los años 80 pero no va a ser
la única hasta el 31 de diciembre
cocacola se deshará de al menos dos
centenares de marcas de las 500 que
tiene en total esto se parte de un plan
de reorganización que inició por culpa
del comité 19 lo más llamativo del
asunto son los comentarios en redes
sociales liliana como por ejemplo hay
personas que dicen que eliminen el resto
de marcas pero por favor no lo hagan
contar y otros parecidos y es que esta
marca tenía un muy buen grupo de fieles
que desde hace años se negaban a que
desapareciera volvamos con los
indicadores de la jornada o estoy del
corto una racha de tres días en rojo y
cerró con signos mixtos ayudaron los
datos de ventas minoristas mejores de lo
esperado en europa hubo grandes avances
animados por la bolsa de nueva york
londres llevaba cuatro sesiones en rojo
y hoy subió en américa latina hubo
resultados dispares
con repunte de argentina y descensos en
méxico y en brasil y la cifra al día son
los 3 mil 700 euros mensuales que
corresponden al salario mínimo más alto
del planeta y que entrará en vigencia en
ginebra suiza a partir del sábado una
norma obliga a que desde ahora los
empleados tengan que pagar 23 francos
por hora en la que a su vez es una de
las ciudades más caras del mundo hasta
ahora salario mínimo más alto del mundo
era el de australia gracias ya tener la
pola información de ustedes gracias
continúen con más siembra de 24 puntos
con nos vemos más adelante
[Música]